ننتقل بكم مشاهدينا الى صور مباشره لوصول
الرئيس الصيني الى جزيره بالي في
اندونيسيا لحضور قمه العشرين ويبدو في
استقباله
وفد صيني ضخم وفرقه راقصه تؤدي الرقصه
الاندونيسيه التقليديه على ما يبدو اذا
وفد صيني ووفد اندونيسي في استقبال الرئيس
الصيني لدى وصوله مباشره الان في جزيره
بالي في اندونيسيا لحضور قمه العشرين وكان
قبل ذلك وصل الرئيس الامريكي ايضا الى
بالي لحضور هذه القمه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
اذا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
المباشره لوصول الرئيس الصيني الى جزيره
بالي في اندونيسيا لحضور قمه العشرين
ويبدو ان هناك انباء تتحدث عن قمه مرتقبه
او لقاء مرتقبه بين الرئيس الصيني والرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن خلال هذه القمه
[موسيقى]